[Musik]
jetzt ist es bald wieder soweit
weihnachten steht vor der tür das
schönste fest des jahres
viele deutsche mögen es besinnlich und
bringen sich auf den weihnachtsmärkten
in stimmung
aber die große masse ist woanders
shoppen bis es kracht die geschäfte
rechnen in diesem jahr mit über 90
milliarden euro umsatz im
weihnachtsgeschäft 39 mehr als im
letzten jahr aber das top
weihnachtsgeschenk 2016 ist geld mehr
als die hälfte aller geschenke in
deutschland auf dem zweiten platz
bücher literatur gefolgt von
lebensmitteln zu sich auf platz vier
kleidung und dann natürlich spielzeug
gerade die spielwarenindustrie macht
ihren hauptumsatz zu weihnachten und
dann gibt es ja da noch den
weihnachtsbaum die kosten meistens ab 50
euro aufwärts
je nach wuchshöhe und aussehen
heftige tan haben damit die kugeln gut
hält und dann gerade spitze und einfach
saftig grün
das ist auf jeden fall wichtig dieses
jahr sind die bäume gut gewachsen sie
haben ausreichend regen die meisten
deutschen lassen ihren baum mehrere
wochen im wohnzimmer stehen so lange bis
die nadeln abfallen
rund 30 millionen bäume werden dieses
jahr verkauft 2015 lag die deutsche
firma ein meter 68 dieses jahr dürfte
eher größer ausfallen der hauptbau viele
kaufen noch einen weiteren kleinen der
trend geht zur zweiter für den balkon
oder die terrasse ohne baum
kein gelungenes fest und erraten muss
natürlich auch schnecken auf den
weihnachtsmärkten es die deutschen gern
spanferkel oder bratwurst
die meisten kommen zum essen auf die
märkte sie beginnen schon im november
und dauern bis weihnachten der umsatz
deutschlandweit zweieinhalb milliarden
euro aber zum ersten weihnachtsfeiertag
muss es dann doch ein besonderer braten
sein
nein auf dem teller kommt auf 2016
selten vegetarisches auf platz vier wild
auf platz drei rinderbraten
und jeder sechste deutsche ist schwein
unangefochten auf platz eins ganz oder
rente jeder zweite braten und eine ganze
ganze kostet selten unter 50 euro
wer noch etwas übrig hat spendet zu
weihnachten so locker sitzt das geld
aber nicht nur jeder fünfte deutsche ist
dieses jahr bereit etwas für einen guten
zweck zu geben
das war im letzten jahr noch anders da
lag die durchschnittsrendite von 3 ssig
euro dieses jahr nur bei 32
aber für einige gehört es zum
weihnachtsfest einfach dazu und
natürlich die richtige musik
stille nacht heilige nacht das mit
abstand beliebteste weihnachtslied fast
jeder zweite singt es wenn er nach dem
essen und den ganzen geschenken dazu
noch in der lage ist
[Musik]